[Music]
you know it's funny because you shot a
movie here jay edgar i'm told that you
were on the lot but i don't think i met
you did we ever did our paths ever cross
no uh
not that you know of but our paths did
cross because i don't know i don't know
if you've ever experienced this but like
as a tall guy when you see another tall
guy across the room you're immediately
just like i don't trust that guy like
there's like something shifty about
another talk i always thought you were
gonna say sexually attractive
no that's where i go
well come on people no uh but yeah yeah
i so i was walking on the lot and i saw
a guy in front of me uh you uh who's
as tall as i was and i was just
immediately like i don't like him don't
like that guy
and then you turned a corner and went
into a building i was like oh it's conan
actually i love that guy so uh our paths
never crossed but i did uh stalk you oh
you socked me yeah thank you very much
how tall are you by the way six five
yeah okay uh about my range it depends
on what's going on with the hair yeah
you have better hairs it can be anywhere
between uh six four or six nine
depending
on humidity and uh moose gel um i was
curious like me i went through a
horrible period where i grew did you
grow at a normal rate i grew overnight i
mean i didn't grow at all i was kind of
a short kid in high school and then
somewhere late sophomore year within the
period of about two months like the hulk
yeah i grew yeah yeah yeah burst out of
my clothes 100 in in ninth grade i was
shorter and i had you know like a bit of
a little gut and just a little short
almost pudgy kid and then over the
summer from ninth to tenth grade it was
like everything just went
and just kind of stretched me out i
think i grew
i mean it was like nine inches in like
one summer or something like that now
back me up on this it's painful right
right the word it's not worth it like i
would rather be five eleven like i
remember literally i would get such leg
cramps and yeah
and i lived up on the third floor that's
where they kept me
but i lived up on the third floor and
people in the house are here like yeah
yeah because my my my was having amazing
leg cramps and i was stumbling around
and smashing other things that's part of
the hulk transformation yeah yeah
no it's to say like it's like the thing
where you're did you ever have like your
hips pop out a socket or anything like
that no
oh yeah me neither i mean either it was
just something i heard did your hips
really pop out of your socks yeah yeah
yeah okay you're a freak then i know i'd
be going like up or down a flight of
stairs and step on the stairwrong and
just go
and just like and then
but you know you're so you're so kind of
goofy and lanky at that point that you
kind of hit the bottom and just bounce
and you're like wow all right i guess
i'll just
how you turned out though it all worked
out well for you yeah i'm not
complaining
oh yeah because you're really suffering
here it looks like
on the inside
you know what's funny i want to pay you
a compliment i'm sure you've heard this
a million times uh i went and saw the
social network and i was convinced
that they went out and got twins to play
the winklevoss twins thank you
absolutely convinced yeah and then
someone told me no that's that's army
hammer uh playing both roles and i said
no he's got a twin yeah and i actually
got into arguments with people
and then when i would see the movie come
back on cable i'd still say no no
there's no way that was amazing how that
was done thank you dude i mean i can't
take very much credit for it but it was
like david fincher's genius uh but it's
funny i ran into a lot of casting
directors it was a long time that i was
in this business before i did social
network like years of just getting
constantly rejected and rejected and
rejected then finally that kind of
popped and then i'd run into casting
directors who i'd known for years and
they'd go how come you never told me you
had a twin brother
it's like
you're in this business you should know
this you should know that this is a
trick well do you get recognized a lot
from that movie do they do people think
ever think like hey you're one of those
winklevoss guys you got that on the
street no fortunately no one ever thinks
i'm a winklevoss but uh what i do get is
every now and then someone will walk by
me and just go
facebook or you know like something like
this
that just sounds like they know you from
facebook yeah oh my god
yeah
poke me
we've all yelled out at people